all right so welcome back this is course update 0.4 I believe so I think this
will be the last course update for now because I do not want to like put out
all the information then confuse with confuse you with all the stuff that's
out there just want to put out the useful stuff I believe because and this
update is really really good like I think it's one of my best updates so far
and you will learn a lot of stuff from here so in this video we will learn
about the highs and lows that are formed inside a fair value gap and you can use
this technique to find your daily bus and you can also use it as a model if you
like so over here let's assume that there was a fair value gap price came
into this fair value gap it created a low and then it pushed back up and it went
into this fair value gap right here so this high over here so let's assume
there's if all the fair value gap here right pros went through this fair value
gap and created this high over here inside the fair value gap now let's
assume that we are looking at this on 15 minute time frame so once price takes
out the low that was formed inside this fair value gap we can drop down to one
minute time frame and look for a market structure shift once we get a market
structure shift our next target would be the high that was formed inside the
fair value gap so price is mostly doing this to deliver you know price if that
makes sense so you get a market structure shift then you can look to take your
entry and you can look to target the high over here and that could be your last
take profit level don't forget about the fair value gaps in this leg you can
look to take partials but this should be your draw on liquidity because price
what it does it takes out the low that was formed inside the fair value gap
and goes to the high that was formed inside the fair value gap or it goes to
the high that was formed inside the fair value gap to the low that was formed
inside the fair value just gonna take out the high then it will take out the
low so this is what you can use to find your daily bias monthly bias weekly
bias you can use it as a model itself so you can see we use 15 minutes and one
minute combination then you can use the daily and one hour you can use the four
hour and 15 minutes combination and you can use the weekly and four hour
combination and for monthly you can use the one month and daily time frame
combination sorry for that so yeah that's literally about it for this let me see
if I can find some examples I mean I will find sample I was trying to find
examples in this video so I'll just pause the video and find the examples in
hindsight and then I'll let you know